You might have noticed that moving
the decimal place to the right
decreases the power that 10 is raised
to, and that moving the decimal place
to the left increases
the power the 10 is raised to.
So, every time we move the decimal
to the right one place,
as we do with .27 to 2.7,
we have to take
one away from the number that 10 is
raised to, so we go from 10 to 9.
These numbers are not written
in scientific notation.
For each number, correct it, so
that it is written in scientific
notation by first entering what
the decimal should look like, and
then, entering what power
10 should be raised to.
I'll help with the first one.
33 times 10 to the 3rd should
be 3.3 times ten to the 4th.
If you're having trouble, it might
help to write out the full number, and
then, turn it into scientific notation.